i have a voicemail number which you are
invited to call
any time of day whenever you get the
hankering just give me a call
2192 davidp here's a voicemail i got
about 20 grand i've been waiting for
take a listen to this
okay david i remember a few days ago and
it was last week you mentioned that the
creator of parlor
the conservative twitter clone
said that they would offer a bounty of i
think was it twenty thousand dollars
yes progressive with over fifty thousand
followers or indeed it was vice versa
but by the way you said you tried to
take him up on that and they still can
take you back
and i'm wondering has he ever resolved
that no
so basically yeah parlor you know
republicans
said our free speech rights are being
taken away on twitter
so some guy created an app called parlor
and he said multiple times right around
the july 4th uh
long weekend holiday that if any
progressive with over 50 000 twitter
followers signs up they'll pay them a 20
000 bounty so i have 130 000 twitter
followers i signed up
i tweeted to the guy and i said i'm
ready for my 20 grand
didn't say anything next day i tweeted
again i did what you said i signed up
i'm ready for my 20 grand
still got nothing and ultimately i just
deleted the parlor account so in
addition to being
liars about the circumstances of
censorship on social media
also liars in terms of they said we'll
pay 20 grand if uh
you know i met the requirements and they
did not pay me you may not be surprised
by that
we are going to talk on the we've not
talked a lot on the bonus show about the
return of sports in the coronavirus era
there's actually some really interesting
things going on which i want to discuss
we're also going to talk about a black
woman facing prison for a voting mistake
and prosecutors just doubled the charges
against her and donald trump
has ordered undocumented immigrants
excluded
from a very important census count
remember it's 2020 the census
is going on in the midst of everything
else that's happening all of those
stories
and more on today's bonus show remember
you can get instant i'm talking instant
instantaneous
speed of light access to the daily bonus
show
by becoming a member at joinpacman.com
or
two options become a patron at
patreon.com
davidpakmanshow we'll see you on the
bonus show or if not
tragically we won't see you until
tomorrow